[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka lyra lyra pants on fire in this
video we're breaking down the finale of
his dark materials season two
obviously full spoilers ahead for the
episode and we will be going over
some aspects of the book so if you don't
want any of the big questions
answered or the cliffhanger then i
highly recommend that you turn off now
if you enjoy the video then please drop
a thumbs up and make sure you subscribe
to the channel for breakdowns like this
each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into his dog
materials
okay so the series has a whole host of
things to talk about
and we started off with lyra stepping
through a tear in her dimension that was
created by lord azrael
at a seemingly desolate location known
as the city of angels
she met will parry and together the two
set out on a quest to track down his
father
and the subtle knife i i know this
city's called city gaze
or something but every time i go to
pronounce it i get it wrong so i'm just
avoiding it like the specters
now the knife was capable of cutting
through everything even the fabric of
reality
and well became the bearer along the way
lyra met a character known as dr malone
who had been studying dark matter in
wills
or rather our universe and she quickly
became an
ally but not everyone had lyra's best
interests at heart
he watched as lord boreal two sought the
knife
and he actually was taken out in quite
shocking fashion
elsewhere lee scores be tracked down
will's father john parry
who was masquerading under a new
identity
john insisted that lee take him to the
city as a
city of angels as he was told he would
meet the bearer of the subtle knife
and episode 8 followed everyone heading
towards this location
whilst trying to fight off the forces of
the magisterium
now i'm not going to be doing a recap
per say as you've probably watched the
episode
rather i just want to skim through the
plot whilst answering the big questions
surrounding this entry first one you may
have is
who are the creatures that ruta comes
face to face with
during the beginning of the episode well
these are actually cliff gasts
who you may remember from attacking lyra
and lee in season 1
when they were on the former's balloon
the cliff ghasts worship a blind prophet
who they refer to as grandfather and the
deity actually predated
humans this grandfather predicted that
the battle to end all battles would come
one day
and that lord azrael would be the victor
if he possessed the subtle knife
which they call the asahetra pro
probably butcher the pronunciation of
that too but never mind
this is why when will wakes up after the
intro we too hear a voice in his head
discussing a weapon that's powerful
enough to destroy the authority
and in season three expect to see a lot
more discussion on this
now as for lord azrael it feels like
forever since we last saw him
and at one point i was actually thinking
that we might not even get james mcavoy
at all
however at the end of this entry we
catch him recruiting the rebel angels
and learning that he needs to get the
knife in order to win
the word asahetra actually translates to
god destroyer
and thus it is the key to defeating the
magisterium as
they of course are a religious group so
we have several characters learning that
their destiny is tied to it
and this of course will cause a lot of
issues down the line
now angels in this world mean something
slightly different
similar to how demons carries an
alternate meaning to it
angels are actually made completely out
of dust
and they will become paramount in
defeating the authority
however that doesn't mean that things
will be easy for azrael
due to his treatment of roger we know
that the guy has no chill when it comes
to killing kids
and lyra of course still holds a grudge
against him
we'll discuss roger later on but i do
think that going forward
will and lyra will be at odds with him
though it won't last too long
going off the source material now if
you're wondering what the war itself is
well it all has to do with dust dust is
seen as being given by the angels
and many view it as the thing that gives
humanity free will
this allows humans to do as they please
and therefore
it is possible for them to live sinful
lives thus the magisterium want to take
dust away from humanity so that people
are no longer tempted by their desires
and in turn the authority will be able
to control them
this is what azrael wants to stop and
why the character will need the knife
now mrs coulter also plays a big part in
the entry
and we watch as she wanders through the
city of angels before coming face to
face with lyra
after killing lord boreal it seems like
she's fully on the i don't give an f
mode
and throughout this season we've watched
as she's pretty much caused a war
between the witches and magisterium
just just for a laugh now a big twist
comes when she discovers that lyra is
actually part of the witch's prophecy
and that she goes by the name eve aka
the mother of all
the season was laced with hints towards
this and at one point
boreal whose demon was a snake tried to
tempt her in order to get the
elethiometer
lyra and willa also sort of stand-ins
for adam and eve
as after both gained knowledge that
there was something else
they travelled from their homes and
could potentially start a new world
the magisterium believe that lyra or
other eve
will eventually unleash dust on humanity
and thus they will be completely unable
to control their subjects
juxtaposing this the witches want it to
happen as it will finally give the world
free will
and mean that people are no longer bowed
by a group of religious zealots
in our culture eve is sometimes looked
down upon
as she represents someone weak world who
fell victim to temptation
and she's pretty much responsible for
making humanity be cast out of the
garden of eden
however dark materials just alter this
slightly
and instead of having her as someone
who's a representation of sin
she's seen more as a person who
represents knowledge
eve is seen as someone that ate the
fruit from the tree of knowledge
and this of course gave humanity the
ability to think for itself
however the magisterium see those that
possess knowledge
and question things as basically heresy
they they say heresy a lot now the
prophecy itself contains a character
known as the serpent
who it is said will try and tempt eve
this serpent will give her a choice of
whether to unleash dust on the world or
not
and thus it will allow the humans to
question things even more
but who exactly is this serpent well
spoilers for the book but it's actually
revealed in the end to be mary malone
now we don't know whether lyra will give
into this but if eve has anything to go
by then she likely will
and humanity will have to deal with the
consequences of fully getting their free
will for better or worse
her mother will likely throw some
spanners in the works and it's going to
be interesting to see how their
relationship develops over the next
season
there's a really interesting bit at
about the midpoint of the episode
in which we see colter furious at a
demon for doubting that she should help
lyra
i think this is because it knows that
there's only one way that it can really
go
and if coulter is willing to help lyra
no matter what then
both her and the demon's life will be at
risk she some inspectors at one point
and i love how she and azrael are
characters that you can't really get a
read on
they seem evil but have done good from
time to time
and are by far some of the most complex
people in the show
they make for a great double act and
speaking of double axe
we watched the death of both john parry
and lee scorsby in this episode
i've seen a lot of people shocked that
the two both died
and is confirmed by their demons
disappearing which cements that they are
indeed gone
however that doesn't mean they're gone
for good and both john and lee have a
way in which they can return
now i'm jumping ahead a bit here but the
post credit scene of the episode has an
appearance by roger parslow who of
course died in the first season
i'm guessing a lot of people are
confused over this but this is actually
a key element in the third book
and we discover that he's in the land of
the dead which is basically the
afterlife in the saga
the domain is hell and the authority
roam over this dimension
torturing those who they view as living
sinful lives
now i'm not sure exactly on the
chronology of this as
it seems weird that lyra goes from being
with coulter
to ending up in the land of the dead i
do have a theory though that this might
actually be a flash forward
or rather a scene from the third season
as this location
doesn't pop up until much later in that
novel now in the work
using the subtle knife will and lyra
travel to this dominion
and this is where they commit to freeing
the spirit's trap there
so there is indeed a way that jon and
lee can both come back
i really hope they get it as i found
both their deaths quite touching
now watching i'm not crying now watching
john die after saving will was
a really shocking moment and it kind of
sucked for the character that he'd come
all this way
only to have his dad die before they
could have more father and son moments
together
i think will blamed his dad for a lot of
things that happened
but accepted in the end that he was
trying to serve a higher purpose
he's also the one who made will accept
that he was the night bearer
and instilled in him this idea of duty
before he saved his life
now the episode ends with mrs coulter
coming across lyra
and she basically kidnaps the character
and takes her with her
going forward from this part and delving
into what kicks starts the third book
we actually see that because colter
knows lyra is the next steve
that she will not let her out of his
sight and similarly the first season
she will keep her captive due to her
escape last time the pair were together
i don't think she'll be as easy on her
and instead
lyra will need help from a higher power
now in the third volume
angels actually go to will and tell him
that he must give azrael a knife in
order to fight the authority
however he doesn't and instead he goes
after lyra who has been hidden in a cave
i'm not going to be spoiling the full
work beyond what i have but together
they then travel to the land of the dead
which is why i believe that this scene
with roger is a flash forward
apologies if that's ruin anything but i
think i kind of had to talk about the
bits in between in order to get up to
the bit about roger
in the post credits scene we see lyra
saying what is this place
so she had to arrive there somehow which
i think the opening episode of season 3
will fill in
now as for the show as a whole i found
it a bit hit and miss a point
i kind of wish that we got more of the
specters as well as the sinister
side of the series i've seen a lot of
people say that this entry was boring
and looking at my views on my earlier
videos i'm not sure many people are that
interested in it
however i do think that the series was
worth sticking with and those who know
what happens in the third volume
will be aware of just how much things
heat up overall though it wasn't perfect
i did enjoy this entry and kept coming
back to it every week
even after i stopped doing breakdowns on
it now i did have a lot of people ask
why these suddenly ceased
and it's purely down to the fact that a
lot of people weren't watching them
i know that's kind of a crappy way to
handle content as most of you will watch
your video no matter who else does
but i actually do this full time and and
every video takes about six
to ten hours to make so when you're
putting in what could end up being
70 hours which is pretty much two full
weeks of work
and not getting much back for it it does
become frustrating rather than fun
i kind of have to choose what topics i
cover carefully as those are basically
what keep me in the job
i mean i can keep making videos in the
long run which is why i step back from
covering the show
again nothing to do with my feelings
towards this series but when you're
self-employed
you kind of have to think about your
living a lot of the time
anyway i know many of you won't care
about that but this is a your question
censored video
so i thought i'd answer the one i've
personally been asked the most
hope you guys understand and enjoy the
last breakdown and i will of course be
covering the end of season 3.
overall i did really enjoy his dark
materials i know the first season
was better in my opinion this had enough
to keep me coming back
hopefully next time we get more of a
relationship between lyra
and her parents as that seems sorely
missing but as far as developing the one
that she has with will
i i can't fault it too much his dark
materials was a cool second season
and it gets a 7 out of 10. and don't
forget that on the 30th of december
we're giving away three copies of the
lord of the rings 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the season
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button and
as a thank you you get videos like this
early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
how to kill wonder woman which will be
linked on screen right now it's probably
one of my favorite videos i've ever made
and we go through all of the best ways
to take it down
if the occasion ever comes to it without
the way thank you for sitting through
this
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace